oui
[Musique]
la gironde le plus grand estuaire
d'europe commence là où les eaux de la
dordogne de la garonne se mêlent en un
perpétuel affrontement avec l'océan
de tout temps des marins rompu aux
difficultés de la navigation locales ont
prêté assistance au bateau en les
pilotant sur l'estuaire parfois au péril
de leur vie
[Musique]
aujourd'hui malgré le secours des
instruments modernes les risques
demeurent et les pilotes sont toujours
présents pour accueillir et guider les
navires
quand on vient de l'océan la bx à et la
première bouée sur la route de bordeaux
c'est une bouée d'atterrissage bx pour
bordeaux a pour atterrissage située à
quelque 20 kilomètres du phare de
cordouan
elle marque l'entrée du chenal
[Musique]
cette hauteur de cette bouée loin du
regard des terriens que les bateaux
descendant la gironde débarquent leurs
pilotes avant de gagner la haute mer
et c'est là aussi que les pilotes vont
servir les navires remontant l'estuaire
et les conduire à bon port sur cette
voie maritime que l'on appelle le rail
de bordeaux
bon
en un va et vient incessant les pilotes
revivent chaque jour la même aventure
depuis des siècles face aux pièges de
l'embouchure et ceux de la rivière comme
les marins d'ici nomme la gironde
nous aimons ça m'aurait speed hassouna
ce possible
[Musique]
non
sur les dangers de l'estuaire christian
mot san marin au pilotage pendant 22 ans
un point de vue sans équivoque ah oui la
sueur est très dangereux moi d'ailleurs
je m'insurge contre les gens qui font
actuellement de la plaisance et chivu
diderot la rivière de gironde c'est
pratique c'est facile
non non non non la rivière de gironde
comme l'entrée de l'estuaire
c'est très dangereux d'abord nous avons
les rochers du côté cordouan ce qu'on
appelle les battures de cordouan
nous avons le banc de la mauvaise qui
porte bien son nom
nous avons la passe ou la mère rendre
énormément j'ai vu des grès de 13 à 14 m
des courants violents
et partout de s'étendre aux petits
navires qui tombe en travers d'un
ouvrage même en rivière bon eh bai
suivant comment ils tombent en travers
il peut chavirer il peut se crever il
peut couler les courants en vivo amène
sa cousine de courant ce qui ne permet
pas un homme de pouvoir nager ni de se
rattraper si si la reynière de gironde
est très dangereux
donc pour les marins qui arrive dans
l'estuaire de la gironde
on a une cote véritablement
inhospitalière il faut bien se rendre
compte que l'estuaire est très restreint
pour ses passages navigables donc les
navires ont tendance à être rapidement
drossés à la côte
la plupart des naufrages ont vraiment
marqué les populations locales au point
parfois de donner le nom du naufrage à
un lieu je pense au gallon d'or la
pointe espagnole le la pointe du rhin
donc là on a une carte qui datent de
1813 écart très intéressant puisqu'elle
donne une perspective assez originale de
la côte saintongeaise maritime avec des
bandes de sable bouge sans cesse on
imaginait bien que les navigateurs qui
sont en difficulté ont très peu de zones
d'affirmer ou de refuges
on passe le cap pour s'engager le long
de l'embouchure de la gironde en passant
par le banc de la mauvaise
là encore le banc de la mauvaise le nom
n'est pas innocent c'est un c'est un des
bancs les plus dangereux de l'estuaire
de la gironde des hauts fonds là encore
des bancs de sable qui bouge sans cesse
des bancs énorme mais malgré le feu de
cordouan le malgré le phare c'est une
zone d'une très grande difficulté
nautiques 1 et les pilotes sont les
seuls à connaître suffisamment bien la
côte pour pouvoir naviguer
sachant qu'il faut passer au plus près
parce que les profondeurs les plus
importantes sont justement le long de la
côte de saint palais par exemple c'est à
partir de leur maison du verdon que les
pilotes véritable aiguilleur des maires
organisent à tour de rôle la gestion du
service au navire pour les remonter et
les descentes de l'estuaire
un nouveau bateau qui arriveront mais on
crée une planche l1 de ce qu'on appelle
un chatoyant le bateau ils arrivent
monde mais là et bien après au fur à
mesure va arriver a jugé qu' apple et
puis on appréhende redescend donc une
planchette c'est un bateau et donc il ya
le moment où vous prenez le cas je sais
pas moi là on a des heures un président
vous prenez ce bateau là ya pas de en il
arrive le 17 le 17 c'est demain il doit
charger la dombes ain pétrole il va
charger allonge bon c'est son départ le
donge qui va conditionner son arrivée
ici
bon ça se trouve dans l'après midi je
vais avoir une heure précise donc une
fois qu'on commence à voir une heure
précise dans le met dans l'est
monter certaines et puis reprend
organiste et donc après oui vraiment
géré les les pylônes pour dire un tel
fait elle est celle bateaux sont pas
contre la logistique qui a derrière
c'est qu'il faut mettre les pieds il
faut mais récupéré fois en mai une
voiture soit on a nos chauffeurs ya
toute cette logistique qui va derrière
fois et c'est vrai qu'on n'imagine pas
on n'imagine pas non plus le nombre de
navires et de marins ou guti par l'océan
cet endroit il y a là un véritable
cimetière de bateaux bien connue des
plongeurs de la dame ac le club
subaquatique de la cotinière
nous plongeons actuellement sur l'épave
du pôle premier du nom de son inventeur
tu n'es pas vendre loi d'une trentaine
de mètres de long qui a été découverte
il ya quelques années sur laquelle nous
menons un sondage depuis maintenant neuf
ans cette année nous avons eu la chance
de découvrir la cloche du navire qui en
un formidable c'est peut-être avoir la
chance d'avoir ça le nom du navire soit
une batte et par rapport aux archives
que l'on a déjà sur les naufrages
long de cette côte nous allons pouvoir
identifier sauna bien
[Musique]
en juin 2008 nous avons plongé avec le
club de l'anac sur une épave qui est au
large de l'île d'oléron par 15 20 m de
profondeur et sur laquelle on a trouvé
un lock et une fourchette qui nous ont
permis une identification du navire qui
en fait les pubs du vapeur anglais le
dos relais donc des recherches qui ont
été menées aux archives départementales
et on a retrouvé l'histoire de ce
naufrage
[Musique]
nous sommes en avril 1987 la tempête
fait rage dans l'estuaire de la gironde
et le vapeur se diriger sur sur bordeaux
et le pilote n'a pas de possibilité de
monter à bord les conditions sont en
train extrême il ne peut pas et comble
de malchance le vapeur va avoir une
avarie moteur
et il va dériver suite à cette avarie
pour faire naufrage sur le plateau de la
charbonnière sur l'île d'oléron
on a l'exemple type de l'utilité de ces
pilotes puisque dès le départ si le
pilote avait pu gagner le navire il
aurait vraisemblablement pu en éviter la
perte
aujourd'hui grâce à l'hélicoptère nous
sommes en mesure de mettre à bord des
pilotes dans des conditions de récupérer
des pilotes dans des conditions météo ou
le bateau pilote n'aurait pas travaillé
lors été à l'abri bien avant avec
l'hélicoptère envolé jusqu'à forcer
l'iss deux jours les mouvements de
navires ne sont pas trop gênant pour les
treillages et il est clair qu'on met
aujourd'hui les pilotes dans des
conditions pires qu'avant à bord d'un
navire depuis l'antiquité la route de
bordeaux était très fréquenté et les
capitaines de navires avaient à leur
disposition des cartes grossièrement
dessinés et terriblement incertaine on
doit la première carte de la gironde
daté de 15 145 alphonse de saintonge qui
fut pilote de jacques cartier un pilote
hauturier c'est à dire celui qui peut
calculer la hauteur des astres et
l'utiliser pour cela un instrument
rudimentaire l'arbalète ou battants de
jacobs pièces de bois sur laquelle
coulisses des réglettes et comportant
une encoche pour viser le soleil ou les
étoiles
alphonse réaliser des triangulations le
long des rivages complété par des
relevés à la boussole et à la lunette d'
approche ces va-et-vient sur la côte et
l'utilisation d'instruments bizarres lui
faisait courir le risque d'être
soupçonné par les paysans et les
religieux de se livrer à quelques
pratiques hérétiques
ils devaient se presser de faire des
mesures alors
au moment de reporter les indications
recueillies il était bien obligé de
faire jouer sa mémoire est un peu son
imagination
[Musique]
sur la carte d'alphonse on voit le phare
de cordouan sous le nom de riz kordan la
cob re pour la coubre
les tours d château-d'oléron de royan et
deux allemands et les moulins de mai
chez renommés pour leur farine dont on
faisait les gâteaux de mer pour les
marins au long cours
[Musique]
face à cette carte improbable les
capitaines avait intérêt à choisir un
bon pilote
certes il y avait les feux mais quel feu
[Musique]
afin de guider et protéger le commerce
maritime bordelais le pape grégoire 9 au
xiiie siècle avait fait construire à
cordouan une tour d'une dizaine de
mètres de hauteur des ermites il
entretenait un feu nuitées joue
on a retrouvé des documents accusant les
moines de négligence et leur proposant
toutes sortes de combustible propre à
accentuer la lumière la nuit et la fumée
le jour mélange de bois de poids et de
goudron graisse de baleine huiles de
poisson mais d'autres feux ceux des
naufrageurs s'allumer sur les pointes de
graver d'arvert afin de tromper les
capitaines et d'attirer les navires à la
côte
les pilotes eux-mêmes n'étaient pas à
l'abri de ces mésaventures dont les
romans du xixème siècle était friand
gucht hissé au mât de sa chaloupe une
immense lanterne de corps un pilote se
laisser prendre à cette ruse infernale
bientôt la quille de son navire venait
se briser sur les rochers et la mère se
couvrait de débris et d'hommes
on comprend pourquoi
depuis longtemps les capitaines des
bateaux préféré s'adjoindre des marins
connaissant parfaitement l'embouchure de
l'estuaire et ses dangers la rivière et
ses embûches au long des 120 kilomètres
les séparant du port
les premiers pilotes furent sans doute
des pêcheurs de saint palais et plus
proches de l'embouchure et les baigneurs
sur la plage ne se doutent pas qu'ils
luttent ici un port de pilotage jusqu'à
la fin du xviiie siècle les premières
embarcations des pilotes étaient de
simples canaux armé par quatre ou cinq
marins et manoeuvré à l'aviron
tel celui avec une petite voile d'avant
reproduit dans l'album de jouve en 1679
les pêcheurs parfois accompagnés de
leurs enfants souvent très jeunes partez
loin en mer au devant de leurs clients
naviguant plusieurs jours par tous les
temps dormant dans les voiles
guettant le navire pour arriver les
premiers et enlever le marché
[Musique]
six corps doit en fut le premier phare
chef d'oeuvre d'architecturé commencé en
1585 d'autres furent édifiées au cours
des siècles afin d'éclairer la route de
l'estuaire entre la pointe de grave et
la coubre en 200 ans on en compte 22
construit en bois en pierre ou en fer et
qui furent détruits par le feu
les tempêtes le recul des côtes quand
ils n'étaient pas démonter et
reconstruit plus loin il y eu des
tentatives de balisage dépasse les
premières balises étaient fabriqués avec
des tonneaux ou des paniers d'osier
lesté d'une ancre à la fin du 19e siècle
arrivent les bateaux feu comme celui du
grand bond ancré au large de bonne anse
où celui de talent et près du verdon
aujourd'hui il reste 5 phares dont la
lumière perce la nuit de l'embouchure
celui de la pointe de grave
le neuvième au même endroit depuis 60
ans les autres ayant été détruits par la
mer l'érosion marine
le phare de cordouan est appelée à juste
titre le phare des rois classé monument
historique
il se visite à la belle saison depuis le
verdon et royan
[Musique]
oui
la coubre 64 m le plus haut de tous
domaines la côte sauvage en face du banc
de la mauvaise
berne aigre à saint palais il porte ce
nom car autrefois dit on ont fabriqué
ici du charbon de bois
enfin
le phare du chai détruit pendant la
guerre furent construits au milieu des
maisons de ce paisible quartier de royan
si leur rôle demeure manifestent les
phares de l'embouchure sont maintenant
second départ le radar de la palmyre le
plus important de france
ensuite il est recommandé aux navires et
à leurs pilotes de suivre tel les
cailloux du petit poucet les 80 balise
se met jusqu'à bordeaux est surveillé
avec constance par ceux du baliseur
cascade
en effet
mais
[Musique]
hervé tu me dis que tu es prêt ok notre
responsabilité c'est de toujours pouvoir
balisés
cette base de l'ouest que les bouées
fonctionne surtout la nuit notamment
avec leurs feux et des cas une bouée qui
part ou qui déraille comme lundi de
pouvoir la remettre sa position le plus
rapidement possible aidées qu'il y ait
un changement de fond se réunit devant
des commissions nautique local pour
décider de l'endroit où va repositionner
les bouées pour permettre toujours
l'avenir de la ligne en toute sécurité
avec une influence suffisante par
rapport leur tyrannie
la base de l'ouest est signalé un
premier lieu par l'amour d'atterrissage
mix se trouve à 21 milles du port du
verdon 4 à 5000 après la bouée
d'atterrissage les premiers couples
debout et valises la passe de l'ouest il
ya quelques années on a refait un
positionnement des bouées pour un
meilleur balisage donc on a mis des
bouées en couple l'une en face de
l'autre
alors qu'auparavant elle se trouvait en
quinconce ou dans les virages
la base de l'ouest et dangereuse par le
fait qu'il ya beaucoup de houle qui
rentrent du golfe de gascogne donc
défense élevé au large ont déferlé c'est
long et ça peut être très dangereux les
premières traces écrites faisant état de
pilotes sur la gironde ont été relevées
par claude renard ancien pilote qui a
des chiffres et des milliers de
documents notariés aux archives de la
gironde
voici un des registres du notaire dont
zoo de la ville de bordeaux bien entendu
ce registre de 1550 et on a trouvé là le
premier document concernant les pilotes
de la gironde on trouve le nom de trois
pilotes s'appelait louis du tour pierre
de bonne garde et raymond prier qui
étaient dits bourgeois de bordeaux
maligne et ceux qui voulaient lire
mariniers à l'époque et pilote de la
rivière de gironde en 16 180 avec les
ordonnances de colbert
la profession trouve un début de
réglementation il y à des pilotes dans
presque tous les pores de la gironde
parmi tous les documents que qui figure
jada aux archives dc départementale de
la gironde
j'en ai extrait un qui est tout à fait
caractéristique de la difficulté de de
ce métier de pilote de l'entrée de
l'estuaire de la gironde le 5 du présent
mois de février 1776 c'est un rendu au
verdon avec sa chaloupe équipé de tout
son nécessaire comme d' usage ayant
battu la mer pendant quelques temps il
fit rencontre vers les 11 heures du
matin d'un navire alors le pilote donc
melon montent à bord de ce navire
anglais et le pilote pria le capitaine
de les fournir un homme pour descendre à
sacha l'eau
mais quelques jours plus tard le pilote
melon devant le greffier de l'amirauté
dépose intérêts de témoignages rendez
vous compte monsieur le greffier
malgré la tempête qui se levait le
capitaine n'a pas voulu secourir monfils
resté sur ma chalus je me suis jeté à
ses pieds je les suppliant gémissant et
en pleurant de me laisser manoeuvrer
gelé priés de faire mettre bas les
voiles des têt et de larguer la misaine
pour attendre mon fils il n'a rien voulu
entendre
oui monsieur à cause de ce capitaine
mon fils est noyé macha loupé détruites
ballon remettez-vous mon ami vous me
dites que vous avez conduit le navire à
pauillac
ce très bien
je vais consigne est votre rapport elle
c'est bien beau tout ça mais ça ne va
pas me rendre mon fils et mon bateau je
demande justice donc la chaloupe a été
perdu avec le fils du pilote se
conduisent une affaire affreuse
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai pu trouver
ça c'est un document tout à fait
frappant et marqueurs vraiment ce métier
de pilote qui était un métier de tous
les dangers mais il n'y avait pas que
des dangers heureusement et aussi des
belles journées et tout ça vers le
milieu du 19e siècle les bateaux de
pilotage sont construits à royan
bordeaux lormont libourne ou mornac
on reconnaît les chaloupes et les quatre
pilotes à une large bande blanche peinte
sur leurs pas voit le long de la coque
les voiles sont frappés des lettres bx
d'une encre et d'un numéro
d'immatriculation
les pilotes étaient vécues par la
population littoral comme des sortes de
chevalier des mers cela à mon avis des
héros parce que vivre sur ses petits
bâtons de 14 15 mètres aller chercher
les bateaux jusqu'à sous l'île d'yeu où
ou à la corogne en espagne
dans lieux de chasse c'était le golfe de
gascogne la est pas c'était pas toujours
rigolo quelquefois ils partaient avec un
capitaine en mousse et trois pilotes et
c'était le mot ce qui ramené le bateau
je vous laisse imaginer quand même un
type 2 de cézan 17 morts 17 ans même pas
15 ans 16 ans qui se permettait de
ramener en cotre pilote des bateaux qui
avait 90 mètres 100 m² tôt à l'abord là
tout seul quand même leur bateau était
tellement performants qu'ils furent
parmi les promoteurs des régates de
royan et de pauillac
après 1850 ce qui leur ouvre les portes
des maisons bourgeoises et en firent les
acteurs incontournables des fêtes
nautiques de la belle époque
e
au port du château d'oléron au chantier
robert l'église des charpentiers de
marine perpétuent les gestes de leurs
anciens il parle des bateaux pilotes
avec le respect dû à leur réputation
la plus belle époque parce qu'on peut
parler de la beauté d'élégance de ses
navires en fait c'est 1870-1880 10 après
le bateau commence à évoluer
on retrouve le gréement évolue également
on retrouve les premières plantations de
gréement de deux fluke ou de contrats
pub ou d'un décevant les appellations
locales et ensuite les cotes évoluent
dans toutes les sociétés nautiques au
niveau des régates
il y à une catégorie réservée aux
bateaux de service on trouve sur
pauillac notamment une série de régates
où il ya toujours 3 trois chaloupes
pilotes qui se font qu'ils se tirent la
bourre comme on dit pour améliorer leur
qualité leur réflexe est de l'année une
certaine évolution des carènes et des
choses comme ça quoi on essaie d'être
performant on est à la concurrence c'est
le premier bateau qui arrive à la
rencontre du bateau qui vient du large
qui va donner le pilote à bord donc il
est important pour eux c'est leur gagne
pain
il faut aller le plus vite possible donc
il faut sans arrêt améliorer les
conditions du bateau on demande de plus
en plus souvent à des architectes navals
de dessiner des bateaux après les
chaloupes
l'évolution se fait lente et nous
arrivons à ce type dans les années 1910
donc toujours d'un pilote de la rivière
de bordeaux ceux ci et là pas d'elle par
les chantiers garraud donc à royan
là on est dans le sublime qu'en fait le
le bateau a complètement évolué on peut
faire carrément au niveau de
l'esthétisme de la concurrence à
certains yak
que s'est il passé en fait la voilure a
été énormément divisée c'est en fait une
valurent à différents paliers
selon les allures de vent selon la force
des vents on évolue on met la
grand-voile phoque traque est le lui
nier quand il ya petit temps le tape cul
pour servir à léquilibre vélique
garot était un chantier qui travaillait
énormément pour le pilotage pour les
bateaux de pêche locaux mais également
pour la plaisance il reste actuellement
un bateau navigant qui vient d'être
restaurée donc qui est sorti de ses
chantiers en 1911 qui est le minable
parfaitement représentative de cette
époque de la construction navale
jacques briois a consacré quinze ans de
sa vie à la restauration exemplaire du
minaouët
[Musique]
alors minaouët 2 c'est une histoire
simple et très compliqué comme tous ces
bateaux qui ont pratiquement un siècle
d'existence
ce bateau a été commandée par un
armateur
de saint nazaire dans les années 1910
l'époque de la belle plaisance bien
évidemment est stable à voulez vous les
amateurs de plaisance alors à l'époque
on allait en angleterre chez five par
exemple tous les inconscients un bateau
il a choisi d'aller plus proche de nous
d'un à royan où il y avait un
constructeur célèbre qui s'appelle
augustin gouraud qui dirigeait les
chantiers de foncillon il était le voir
bien jouer un bateau de plaisance à voir
ce brave monsieur brou faisait des
bateaux de pêche ou des pilotes
deux jambes donc on lui a construit pour
la plaisance un pilote de gens alors les
pilotes de gironde c'est des bateaux
assez fabuleux parce que c'est les
bateaux de merde parler très loin mais
c'est aussi des balles ou des bateaux de
pertuis parce que faut savoir que c'est
sûr de la gironde il ya beaucoup de
bancs de sable et ses bancs de sable les
pilotes doivent aller très vite le
premier pilote arrivés à bord d'un
bateau à l'époque avait le boulot donc
il fallait des bateaux maniable passant
un peu partout rapide est manoeuvrable
uniquement par deux personnes alors
voilà comment ce bateau a été construit
il a été construit pour la plaisance sur
les formes et les plans d'un pilote de
gironde
on est arrivé à se dire au revoir
est-ce qu'on pousse le bateau de côté et
qu'on s'en sert comme modèle pour en
faire un oeuf ou en restant celui là moi
je voulais restaurer on l'a entièrement
démontée on a rêvé 15 ans devoir aller à
l'eau et c'est aujourd'hui qu'il y va
voilà
[Musique]
au niveau mondial est bon un peu partout
un certain nombre et quand on vit à
passer par seulement qu'on mérite de
prendre le chemin principal on gagne
deux à trois heures donc c'est pas tout
était fait pour ça et en plus il était
fait pour être maniée par trois
personnes
le pilote le patron et à mousse et au
retour il je sais le patron louis donc
gérer des bateaux manoeuvrant rapide qui
soit gironde deux manches plus
d'ailleurs les pilotes c'est les bateaux
mythiques déjà déjà le mot pilote c'est
toute une histoire
il ya une aura autour de m quand vous
barrer un bateau comme ça vous avez la
profondeur à côté de vous elle ses
célèbres pilotes je vous prête attention
à tout cela et c'est exactement ça les
hommes de céder vos classes qui ont
rejoint une autre trempe cet état
d'autres semblables et j'étais des
marins séparément le kursaal du mot par
rapport aux marines et ne proclame était
avait été élevé dans cette dans cette
culture d'arrêter où on leur arrive à la
cheville
c'est pas la bonne volonté qui noie
c'est la connaissance de la mer la
connaissance des bateaux la connaissance
du vent la connaissance des marais
qu'ils avaient cédée pente 8i ça c'était
il se passer à de père en fils et des
tout-petits leurs premiers juges c'était
le cas note la godille la flamme
aujourd'hui la godille mesure 17 mètres
propulsé par deux moteurs de 500 chevaux
comme une machine à remonter le temps
la pilotine va servir à droit mas rares
survivants de l'époque des grands
voiliers de commerce
venant de la rochelle le belem navigue
vers bordeaux avant de gagner québec le
pilote montent à bord et la poignée de
main échangée avec le capitaine est le
symbole des liens particuliers unissant
ces deux familles de marins depuis
toujours
les capitaines ont le plus grand respect
pour lui
on sait bien sûr plus avisés
des pilotes et
vois pas mon cou dans une carrière
complète de souvenirs
plus personnellement contestées
conseils d'un pilote fois qu'elle sera
passée on peut rester entre 100 et 150 m
2 près des caisses distance et ça nous
permet de rester valables
alors en ce qui concerne la responsable
des cures du navire c'est pas qu'il est
aussi bon de le rappeler de savoir que
pitel on restera entièrement responsable
vilotte finalement n'étant que vous
enseignez prochaine verte à deux coeurs
tribaux et on voit la trace vous voyez
la trace du flou qui part carrément et
voyez on voit on voit qu en charge sa
charge sur la brouille c'est pour ça que
je veux pas la serre et surtout relancer
commandant on représente l'armateur et
s'il y avait des gros dégâts c'est
l'assurance de l'armateur qui paierait
donc il est normal que le celui qui paye
quand servent la main si j'ose dire est
donc en droit le commandant et le
responsable du navire c'est lui qui est
le maître berne
[Musique]
dans le chenal un paquebot japonais
double le délai la fonction de pilotes
exigent de s'adapter aux diverses
caractéristiques des navires quand le
navire approche les 8 9 10 m de tirant
d'eau
on passe jusqu'à des 80 centimètres du
fond c'est comme ça qu'on calcule les
montées en tirant d'eau maximal et vous
comprenez que sur un bateau de 200 m
avec 30 mètres de large
il faut placer le bateau de façon très
précise et il faut monter avec la marée
de façon très précise d'ailleurs se
rappelle le timing on a des passages
d'environ cinq minutes disent merci
aux différents endroits en fonction de
ce qu'on souhaite faire il faut savoir
que la difficulté ensuite c'est la
manoeuvre à l'arrivée et il va falloir
ramener le bateau dans des conditions
optimales pour effectuer cette manoeuvre
ouverte en laisse pas ses côtés
merci
[Musique]
avec l'arrivée de la vapeur après 1920
les voiles disparaissent peu à peu le
métier évolue
[Musique]
dernier bateau pilote ça a été le pilote
ait hmid rivière et avait été baptisé en
mémoire avait bien des milliers de bière
qui s'éloignait eux à l'entrée de la
gironde
c'était un peu un métier à risque où on
perd mais beaucoup d'équipages beaucoup
pilotes beaucoup de marins il y avait
deux bateaux et ses deux bateaux a été à
vapeur l'autre était un moteur est
périodiquement on allait sur l'un sur
l'autre de façon à amener les équipages
se former sur place
christian mossant canotiers et michel
ducouret mécaniciens ont filmé et
photographié leur vie à bord des bateaux
pilotes entre 1953 et 1985
[Musique]
oh
le jour de mes 14 ans j'ai embarqué à
bord des bateaux pilotes comme mousse et
à 16 ans je suis passé canotiers alors
le métier de canne haute il consistait à
prendre un pilote à bord du bateau
pilote était stationnaire l'entrée de la
gironde ces bateaux marché uniquement à
l'aveyron on allait au devant des
navires ont déposé le pilote et en
revenait à bord du bateau pilote et ceci
par tous les temps nuit et jour tout le
temps qu'il fasse beau qui passe mon b
[Musique]
aulas il a forcé 8 /
l'eau sur le pont
et on va il ya beaucoup de beaucoup
d'eau de projeter quand même
[Musique]
alors là c'est le coeur le second
capitaine cook et ont repéré le petit
bateau en difficulté
le petit pêcheur de la rochelle
[Musique]
à la bx 1 on est un station celle hôtel
flottant et il y a les bateaux qui
arrivent du large
ce sont les bateaux qui monte et il y
aura aussi les bateaux qui descendent
qui viennent de bordeaux et qui
descendront vers la mer ces bateaux là
il faut les servir soit en entrées soit
en sortie fowler faut récupérer le
pilote qui vient de bordeaux où leur
donner un pilote qui vient du large
alors ça c'est le service même du bateau
puis note
un bateau c'est un petit peu la cité
utopique ou qui doit vivre en autarcie
qui doit vivre en autonomie
alors il faut être efficace ou être
disponible il ya toujours le service qui
qui prime et il ya peu de loisirs à ceux
à cette époque là il y avait peu de
loisirs on a été c'était surtout le
travail la qualité du travail et
l'efficacité
d'abord à bord de ces bateaux il y avait
une amitié une amitié qui était forte
on faisait une famille ont passé plus de
temps à la mer qu'à la maison
les moments les plus émouvants pour moi
ça a été les noël par exemple un noël au
large pour moi c'était quelque chose
merveilleux c'était bon joueur mais
c'était beau avec le recul et mauvais
moments c'est quand eux malheureusement
il se passait des drames
j'ai vu des copains se noyait xavi ravel
canaux en récupérer le canot on
retrouvait plus l'homme alors ça c'est
des choses qui sont qui sont graves et a
toujours dans la vie dans marais la
hiérarchie était très présente même si
c'était pas militaire mais c'était le
capitaine le chef mécanicien les
responsables tant que respecté et
respectable mais le pilote lui et l
aristocrate parfait donner vraiment le
l'attitude d'un monsieur de monsieur
arrivée de la pilotine d'angleterre
premières bio teen wolf a fabriqué en
angleterre
là c'est son arrivée
auprès du bateau pilote elle va faire un
hongre l'oim un tour d'honneur pour se
présenter pour faire voir sa
navigabilité
et son efficacité à la servir les
bateaux ce qui était quelquefois mis en
doute par certaines des de l'équipage
l'arrivée des vedettes rapides et
surtout de l'hélicoptère marque la
disparition des bateaux pilotes
ce fut une véritable révolution dans
l'organisation du pilotage
[Musique]
christophe re président du syndicat des
pilotes de la gironde d'essence sur le
mariage n un pétrolier de 172 m et 40
mille tonnes
alan charge et ambarès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après d'arrivée pour aller à bordeaux
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
bien il faut la présence d'un pilote
d'abord parce que c'est obligatoire
d'état français en impose la présence et
ensuite parce que la connaissance des
fonds les particularités locales
le courant les bancs les façons de main
d'oeuvre et les contacts avec les
autorités portuaires enfin rentrer dans
le système portuaire pour un navire qui
ne parlent pas la langue et qui ne
connaît pas du tout les spécificités du
coin c'est quasiment inenvisageable
sinon les risques pour la navigation en
rivière sont surtout dans gironde basse
et les banquiers un peu partout on est
dans un estuaire qui est immense et où
en fait le chemin de la vie gablé est
relativement étroit à l'échelle de la
rive ya ces trois fois rien ici la
rivière fait 10 kilomètres de large
jeunes hommes naviguent a fait 300
mètres de large
donc c'est très peu et on suit une
petite rigole draguer à sept mètres dans
la profondeur est entretenu à 7 mètres
entre le verdon et bordeaux voilà donc
faut pas sortir il faut être vigilant il
faut bien connaître les positions des
hauts-fonds puisqu'il ya quelques au
fond qu'on appelle communément ici les
seuils et qui limite d'ailleurs à
profondeur admissibles chaque jour on
voit là les raisons pour lesquelles en
plus bien sûr le brouillard l'hiver
[Musique]
autrefois les pilotes pour se diriger
sur l'estuaire avaient leur père
appelait amer en langue maritime
c'était un moulin un bâtiment ou un
arbre isolé comme celui d'un sur richard
au xviie siècle
l'arbre fut emportée par la tempête est
remplacé par le phare de richard en 1843
près de là on peut voir une ancienne
pilotine réformer comme un hommage des
pilotes aussi richard
à saint georges de didonne le phare a
été construit en 1900 à la demande des
pilotes pour marquer l'entrée de
l'estuaire au navire sortant des passes
des chaloupes de pilotage échoué sur la
plage jusqu'en 1921
[Musique]
le souvenir des pilotes est gravé dans
la mémoire de la cité comme le sont sur
leurs tombes
les marques de leurs illustres
corporation la pyramide de la garde aux
femmes est un amer du xviiie siècle
il domine les vestiges d'une ville et
d'un grand port gallo-romain l'église de
talmont aussi servait d'amer en 769 les
pêcheurs de talmont créé la première
confrérie des pilotes de la gironde
laquelle a servi d'exemple
puisqu'aujourd'hui les pilotes sont
organisés en syndicats indépendants mais
chaque pilote à son parcours personnel
je suis un milliard monsieur de
s'insérer mais qu'en est il se trouve
que mon oncle était pilote de port à 5
heures j'avais un autre pilote dans ma
famille un autre pilote copilote de la
rochelle et c'est vrai que la marine
marchande m'a assez vite à tirer et la
perspective de devenir pilote plus tard
je m'en cache pas a été un objectif pour
devenir pilote il faut passer un
concours de pilotage qui fouette
titulaire du diplôme de capitaine de
première classe de la navigation
maritime appellation barbare qui a
remplacé celle de capitaine au long
cours qui était pourtant beaucoup plus
politique et il faut réunir à certains
endroits navigation et dans les tacles
des choses il faut ne pas avoir dépassé
35 ans à pauillac
peut-être une idée gurry institutrice
est elle en train d'éveiller des
vocations parmi les enfants qui
l'écoutent
il ya qui était autrefois un port très
important pour les pilotes
c'était le pilote qui dirigeait à ce
moment là le bateau n'est ce pas et qui
connaissait bien sur l'estuaire avec les
parm de sable et que toutes les
difficultés qui pouvaient se présenter à
ce niveau là c'était al ahram que l'on a
mis et malheureusement à cette époque là
on a eu beaucoup de
personnes qui se sont noyées a en
particulier à l'entrée de la gironde
parce que c'était très difficile par
gros temps d'aller à mener les pilotes
ce n'est pas un simple logique d'avenir
de nous les pilotes sur le bateau comme
c'était quelque chose de petit jean luc
rebond soir on va écoutant te prendras
push-pull bâbord avant et pour un
héritage très lourdes amendes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le bar ya m arrive à ambarès il faudra
presque une heure de manoeuvre précise
et délicate pour apporter
demain
à pousser doucement
en janvier qu'on me dicte et tourner
devant
[Musique]
paris berceau stone et procès
la battue
alors le jeu ça consiste à accoster en
essayant de ne pas se servir ni du
remorqueur ni du propulseur
ça ce sont des plus con dao cao ça me
tourne mal mais l'idéal c'est d'arriver
à poser le bateau sur ok s'en servir de
rien juste avec la machine et le courant
est là bas alors on a l'impression
d'aller très lentement mais compteront
pas les repères à terre on a
l'impression qu'on va pas vite mais en
fait on va vite et quand on s'en
approche du quai on se dit tiens je vais
un peu vite quand même parfois si bête
[Musique]
ok étage de tonnes touchera paroisse a à
la fois le retrait bottes ahmed
on avance ce presque plus j'ai
l'impression
elle a reculé d'accord
tous voila c'était ça bonjour à tous
écoutez c'est parfait
on vous passe un botté vous vous
servirez pour les stages
c'est quand même plus agréable de
manoeuvrer avec du soleil en plein jour
que de manoeuvrer en pleine nuit et sous
la pluie faudra peut-être laissé venir à
droite mais on le fera au dernier moment
on ajustera
la responsabilité du conseil du pilote
c'est jusqu'au bateau safe donc ça aide
c'est à dire à marc et correctement en
sécurité c'est toujours un moment unique
celui où l'on quitte un navire a mené à
bon port et également le soulagement
après la tension des derniers instants
qu'il s'agisse du belem ou d'un
pétrolier
[Musique]
m
tha
[Musique]
et quand hors de la vue des côtes le
pilote tristan paillardon abandonne cet
imposant navire lancé vers le large
la simplicité du salut masque une
émotion toujours renouvelée qui montrent
la vraie nature de ces marins
d'exception
[Musique]
il
et